foreign
[Music]
thank you
guys
[Music]
one time
I'm like
[Music]
thank you
distinguished guest the president of the
United States accompanied by the Vice
President of the United States Secretary
of Defense Boyd Austin and General
Charles Brown Jr
thank you
[Music]
good afternoon please everybody thank
you
before I began on undressing
ongoing budget negotiations
Congressional leader I'll be very brief
speaker McCarthy and I have had several
productive conversations and our staffs
continue to meet as we speak as a matter
of fact and they're making progress
I've made clear time and again to fall
in honor national debt is not an option
the American people deserve to know that
there's a Social Security payments will
be there the veterans hospital will
remain open and that economic progress
that we made and we're going to continue
making
fault puts all that at risk
Congressional leaders understand that
and they've all agreed there will be no
default
it's time for Congress to act now
now I want to be clear in the
negotiations we're having with speaker
McCarthy is about the outlines of what
the budget will look like
not about to fall it's about competing
Visions for America
under my Administration we've already
cut to deficit by 1.7 trillion dollars
in our first three years but speaker
McCarthy and I have a very different
view of who should bear the burden of
additional efforts to get our fiscal
house in order
I don't believe the whole burden should
fall in the back of the middle class and
working class Americans my house
Republican friends these are great
instead Republicans passed a bill that
would make huge cuts and important
programs and millions of working and
middle class Americans counters huge
cuts a number of teachers police
officers boarded Patrol agents and
increased wait times for Social Security
claims
and I won't agree to that I put forward
a proposal that will cut spending by
more than one trillion dollars that
freezes spending for the next two years
that's on top of the nearly three
trillion dollars in deficit reduction I
previously proposed through a
combination of spending cuts and new
Revenue raises
I propose making the wealthy begin to
pay their fair share which will reduce
the deficit but it won't cut programs
for hard work in it Americans depending
on it those those funds in order to
continue big tax returns for the
wealthiest Americans America and
America's largest corporations
but we can reduce the deficit both in
short term and long term
the combination of spending cuts and
programs that help big oil and big
Pharma by closing tax loopholes and
making the wealthy pay their fair share
I reduced the deficit I said 1.1
1.7 trillion dollars my first two years
without raising a Cent and raising taxes
above anyone making less than four
hundred thousand dollars
economy is growing
the only way to move forward is with a
bipartisan agreement I believe will come
to the grant that allows us to move
forward and it protects the hard-working
Americans of this country now for the
reason we're here I'm sure you didn't
come and hear that
vice president Harris secretary Austin
representative Calvert representative
Calhoun I assume coming out here
McCullough and I want to thank you all
for joining us as chairman milley I want
to uh I want to start by thanking you I
really mean it for your years of
services chairman and for your lifetime
of selfless commitment to our country
and I also want to thank our your
incredible wife Holly Ann and your two
children Peter and Mary you know uh your
family has served alongside you every
single step of the way it's in our
entire country is grateful as chairman
you've LED our military through the most
complex security environment our world
has faced in a long long time
and we strengthen our alliances from
NATO to the indo-pacific and build new
Partnerships like caucus
we participate we've anticipated new
threats in domains like space and cyber
when you address challenges of transcend
borders and responding to Global
pandemics by tackling the existential
threat of climate change
the we met at the longest war in
American history we continue to take
terrorists off the battlefield and we
rallied the world to stand with the
brave people in Ukraine as they defend
their freedom against Russian aggression
so through everything secretary Austin
and I have had
a candid and direct Council and value
the Insight more than that I truly
enjoyed working I trust you completely
completely it helps set our country and
our military and of course the
inclusively strongest possible position
to succeed
I'm looking forward to continuing our
work together as you finish your terms
and prepare to pass the Baton to your
successful so today I have the honor of
introducing my nominee to be the next
chairman of the joint Chief of Staff
General Charles Q Brown Jr General
welcome General Brown's a warrior
descended from a proud line of warriors
father the U.S army colonel c.q Brown
served in Vietnam his grandfather U.S
army Master Sergeant Robert E Brown Jr
led a segregated Union in World War II
and command pilot General Brown brings
to this role more than 3 000 hours of
study flying experience including 130
combat hours
he knows what it means to be in and
think about it and how to keep your cool
when things get hard
like when your F-16 is on fire
and you returned to the base in Florida
in 1991 CQ had to eject more than 300
more than 300 miles an hour Landing in
the Everglades
that's a lot of fun huh
well I tell you what he's back in the
cockpit the next week for the new call
sign
Swamp Thing
through cross side I asked him inside
the oval what it was like but I'll tell
you about that later General Brown is
also a war fighter who's commanded in
Europe the Middle East and Indiana
Pacific
and he has an unmatched first-hand
knowledge of our operations operational
theaters and a strategic Vision to
understand how they all work together to
ensure the security for the American
people
and while General Brown is a proud butt
kicking on the American Airman First and
always he's also been an operational
leader in the Joint Force
he gained respect across every service
from those who have seen him in action
and have come to depend on his judgment
more than that he gained the respect of
our allies and partners around the world
regard General Brown as a trusted
partner and a top-notch strategist no
matter how complicated the mission I'm
helping build and lead the Coalition now
more than 80 Nations strong to counter
Isis threats in the Middle East
to positioning our Air Force for the
future in Indo in the indo-pacific
General Brown has built a reputation
across the forest as an unflappable and
highly effective leader
as someone who creates an environment of
teamwork trust and and
then executes with excellence and
someone who smokes a mean brisket
understand you have that smoker still
with you you carry that around every
year what was it in your show
but General Brown says he doesn't he
doesn't play for second place he plays
to win and that's obvious
that mindset is going to be an enormous
asset to me as commander-in-chief and to
the United States of America as we
navigate challenges in the coming years
over the past three years
as Chief of Staff of the Air Force
General Obama has become known that for
a signature approach
accelerate change or lose
accelerate change or lose General you're
right on as I've often said our world is
at an inflection point where the
decisions we make today are going to
determine the course of our world for
decades to come
and to keep American people safe
prosperous is secure we have to move
fast and adapt quickly we have to
maintain and combat credible Force
capable of deterring and defeating any
types of threat we have to manage our
competition with China and meet the
reality of renewed aggression in Europe
we need to make sure or retain our
Competitive Edge in an age where
emerging Technologies from Technologies
from AI to 3D printing could
fundamentally change the character of
coffee
General Brown is Chairman I know I'll be
able to rely on his advice as a military
strategist and as a leader of military
innovation
dedicated to keeping armed forces the
best in the world and they are the best
in the history of the world and that's a
fact
I'll also be able to realign if it's a
thoughtful deliberate leader who is
unafraid to speak his mind you know as
someone who'll deliver an honest message
that needs to be heard and will always
do the right thing when it's hard
that's the number one quality a
president needs in a chair that's and
that's the leader and that's the link
that all Americans beat about three
years ago to a general Brown gave an
unflinching video testimonial sharing
his own experience of racism and as deep
love of our country to which is
dedicated his entire adult life
it took real backbone
struck a chord not only with our
military members but with Americans all
across the country
CQ is a fearless leader in an unyielding
Patriot that's why three years ago he
was concerned by the United confirmative
the United States Senate 98-0
I urge the Senate to once again confirm
General brown with the same the same
overwhelming bipartisan support
for his new role as chairman of the
joint Chief's staff
I also want to recognize cq's family his
wife Shireen she is here do you mind
standing stream I know that's
embarrassing you
my son Sean and Ross throughout General
Brown's Stellar career in the Air Force
CQ and Serena always put Family First
and they both know from their own
experience growing up in military
families that it's not just the person
who wears uniformly serves the whole
family the whole family serves and the
whole family sacrifices on behalf of the
nation Serene uncq are two partners in
our dedication to the health and
well-being of the women and men in
uniform and their families
five
five and five initiative is doing
important work to address the greatest
issues affecting military families and
child care
education spousal employment Health Care
and housing
and I know that Jill and I look forward
to working even more closely with you on
these issues through her joining forces
initiative let me close this
this year will Mark the 75th anniversary
of an integrated force in the 70th
anniversary of women serving in the
forest and the 50th anniversary of the
all volunteer folks we're celebrating
the route of our national strength
the most American of ideas
the most self-evident truth
all women and men are accrediting and
that no no more powerful Testament to
this than the Armed Forces of the United
States of America
the steps we've taken over the decades
harness the full diversity of our nation
have grown Armed Forces into the
greatest fighting force I'll say it
again a second time the greatest
fighting force in the history of the
world
and general Brown you've been an
essential leader in making our nation
and our forcing even stronger you've
made history
and you have even made it
the Jeopardy clue
did you know that you made it as a
Jeopardy clue The Daily Double notice
well so thank you General Brown and
charade and the whole family for being
willing to take on this mission
and I can thank no one better suited
think I've known the debit students are
more qualified to lead our Force Through
the challenges and responsibility of hit
and look forward having you at my side
advising me as the next chairman and
helping keep the American people safe
thank you all and thank all the military
in the audience thank you for your
service and thank your families as well
and may God protect our church thank you
Mr President
[Music]
thank you support a final deal Mr
President
[Music]
yeah we're not done yet four months four
months five days three hours who's
counting
[Music]
foreign